merci d'être avec nous Hélène condo et
Morel nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure cette élue
socialiste vous représenter les Français
établis hors de France et c'est
aujourd'hui la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites avec un dispositif policier
sans précédent 13000 policiers et
gendarmes dont 5500 à Paris est-ce que
vous saluez cette décision du ministère
de l'Intérieur de mettre les moyens pour
assurer la sécurité des manifestations
alors assurer la sécurité bien entendu
mais moi je suis assise le ministre
vient de dire qu'il y a mille éléments
qui viennent de l'extérieur certains de
l'étranger c'est que donc ces personnes
ont été
identifiées et je me demande pourquoi
quelque part il n'est pas possible de
les de les empêcher de perpétrer enfin
c'est violence auxquelles finalement le
ministre se prépare moi ce qui me
dérange dans tout cela c'est que jusqu'à
présent nous avons eu des manifestations
pacifiques nous avons eu jusqu'à près de
2 millions de Françaises et de Français
qui ont manifesté dans le calme encadré
par la sécurité des syndicats qui sont
revenus maintenant dans la rue pour
encadrer tout cela et que d'un seul coup
et bien on a besoin de ce chaos on a
besoin finalement de faire peur et
quelque part c'est cette violence va
démobiliser si ceux qui jusqu'à présent
sont descendus manifester et qui
aujourd'hui ne veut pas se retrouver
entre des blagues box d'un côté et les
forces de l'Égypte
vous dites qu'avant les Black Blocs
étaient empêchés d'arriver jusqu'au
manifestation et qu'aujourd'hui ils ne
le sont plus je ne sais pas s'ils
étaient empêchés jusqu'à présent mais là
nous avons un ministre qui vient de
s'exprimer en disant qu'il y a la
possibilité d'avoir des personnes qui ne
viennent que pour perpétrer de la
violence ça attaquer à des magasins à
des voilà et et donc tout cela crée le
chaos mais s'ils sont identifiés
pourquoi est-ce que finalement les
équipements avec lesquels ils peuvent
arriver dans leur sac à dos
sont pas retirés je suis allée
manifester plusieurs fois dans les rues
adjacentes au cortège et bien il y avait
des policiers qui vérifiaient le contenu
des sacs jusqu'à présent pourquoi est-ce
que cela
je l'espère mais alors il ne devrait pas
y avoir de violence tels que celles qui
sont attendues moi je pense que c'est
les moyens d'empêcher toute forme de
violence mais qui ne le fait pas je le
crois dans quel but
ben écoutez le fait de dissuader les
Français
d'aller manifester fait que quand nous
avions de millions s'il y en a plus que
500 000 aujourd'hui parce que les gens
auront peur parce que les gens n'aiment
pas le chaos parce que les restaurateurs
et tous ceux finalement qui sont les
victimes de ces violences bon bien sûr
s'insurger contre ceux qui les comètent
un moment vous savez on tourne
finalement la roue vers dans ce cas
pourquoi déployer 13000 policiers
gendarmes
parce que parce qu'il s'attendent assez
violence et que donc c'est bien qu'ils
veulent les éviter ils veulent les
éviter enfin les éviteront non vous avez
vu jusqu'à présent les scènes de chaos
auxquelles on assiste c'est-à-dire que
la violence a lieu et dans les deux sens
parce que ce qui s'est aussi passé du
côté des policiers aujourd'hui est à
revoir je sais qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'enquêtes mais les violences de
la part des manifestants comme celle des
policiers sont intolérables hier
Emmanuel Macron a reçu à déjeuner
Elisabeth borde des ministres et puis
les dirigeants de la majorité et il a eu
cette phrase il y a un réel projet de la
France insoumise de vouloir délégitimer
nos institutions qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces propos
je pense que c'est irresponsable de la
part de quelqu'un qui est élu depuis six
ans maintenant et qui a fait un choix
très clair d'avoir un régime
présidentiel où toutes les décisions
sont prises à l'Élysée où nous avons
encore un conseil de défense mais enfin
pourquoi est-ce que personne ne pose la
question de la légitimité d'un conseil
de défense qui a été mis en place un
moment ou d'avion la pandémie à gérer
nous étions dans une situation
absolument exceptionnelle qui demandait
en effet des actions exceptionnelles et
la mise en place par en effet de ce
conseil de défense aujourd'hui celui-ci
continue à se réunir les décisions
principales enfin c'est ce que disent
certains ministres sont prises lors de
ce conseil de défense et non plus lors
du conseil des ministres et nous voyons
bien que depuis six ans nous avons les
corps intermédiaires qui ont été
délégitimés finalement de leur fonction
à la fois les syndicats qui reprennent
grâce quelque part à cette réforme des
retraites finalement à la place qu'ils
auraient dû toujours avoir qui n'ont
jamais été invités à l'Élysée quand le
président du aujourd'hui qu'il tend la
main mais pourquoi ne l'a-t-il pas tendu
avant de la proposition de de mise en
place
il dit pour revenir à ce qu'on disait
Olivier Véran il dit qu'il y a un
continuu avant de la violence du
discours politique et la violence dans
la rue visant sans aucun doute la France
insoumise vous partagez ça ben écoutez
moi je trouve que la violence vient du
de l'attitude du gouvernement souvent
nous l'avons vécu moi je l'ai vraiment
très très mal vécu d'ailleurs dans une
des prises de parole je je j'ai exprimé
un sentiment très fin j'ai dit quelque
chose vient de se casser cette semaine
au Sénat même au Sénat ou les débats
finalement bon sont restés respectueux
jusqu'à la fin bon on nous a bloqué le
vote on nous a empêché de nous exprimer
on nous a mais nous avons quand même
continué jusqu'au bout nous avons trouvé
un consensus la majorité je crois Heller
avait pris
alors effectivement Oriane il n'y a pas
qu'à Paris qu'il y a des manifestations
pour cet acte 10 c'est le titre de une
de Nice-Matin et de et de Var-Matin on
attend beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui de
manifestations sont prévues dans les
Alpes-Maritimes à Nice et au Cannet
trois dans le Var à Toulon mais aussi à
Draguignan et à Brignoles de ville moins
importantes mais où la mobilisation est
conséquente et dans le sud-est on a
rarement vu autant de monde dans les
rues à Nice jeudi dernier ils étaient
40000 selon les syndicats à défiler on a
aussi enregistré beaucoup de
perturbations à la fois dans le
centre-ville et à l'aéroport et c'est
une situation qu'on devrait revivre ce
matin et il est à noter effectivement
Oriane que depuis le début du mouvement
toutes ces manifestations se sont tenues
dans le calme pas de casse pas de
débordement pas d'incendie on a même vu
à Nice jeudi des policiers baissés leur
bouclier et enlever leur casque au
passage de manifestants qui qui
scandaient la police avec nous des
scènes qu'on ne retrouve malheureusement
pas forcément partout alors d'où ma
question à la sénatrice Hélène Conway
mouray un peu comme les policiers niçois
Elisabeth borne tend la main au
syndicats et et ses forces d'apaiser la
situation est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
a une petite chance d'y arriver
je crois qu'elle a une petite chose si
elle les entend tendre la main est une
chose écoutez et entendre ce qui est
proposé en est une autre et je me répète
pardon mais il utilise quand même utile
de le faire avant même de présenter ce
projet de loi pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas eu
de consultation il est tout à fait faux
aujourd'hui de la part à la fois du
président comme de la première ministre
de dire qu'il y a eu de très larges
consultations pourquoi est-ce que les
assemblées n'ont pas fait leur travail
nous étions prêts nous avions pléthore
de d'amendement pour améliorer un texte
qui pouvait l'être très largement il y
avait pas d'opposition
à une réforme des retraites nous savons
très bien que sur le plan budgétaire
nous avons besoin de faire des efforts
et de planifier les choses donc nous y
étions prêts mais nous avons eu comme
d'ailleurs depuis six ans maintenant un
gouvernement qui arrive et qui est
tellement sûr de lui-même de posséder la
science infuse et
de surtout de ne pas voir son texte
touché alors qu'il a été préparé par des
services administratifs
dans les ministères et que et bien le
politique est là par le biais des
députés des sénateurs pour apporter
cette élément politique et faire en
sorte en effet la loi qui sera
promulguée
sera la plus juste possible juste dans
tous les sens du terme et donc voilà
tout ce travail n'a pas été fait en fait
ce texte a été présenté comme les autres
auparavant c'est-à-dire qu'ils nous est
imposé pendant 5 ans l'assemblée votée
absolument tout ce qui lui était proposé
bon maintenant avec le 49-3 il ne vote
plus donc il ne sert pas à grand chose
et au Sénat et bien nous avons continué
à essayer de travailler avec finalement
limitant les dégâts pour pour un certain
nombre de textes donc en fait c'est une
méthode c'est à dire que ils ont raison
je crois que si vous rejouez un petit
peu les débats au Sénat le terme de
mépris de
il y a des termes qui sont revenus dans
le débat c'était des sentiments qui
étaient exprimés alors on n'est pas là
pour faire du pathos bien évidemment
mais enfin je crois que les uns et les
autres se sont exprimés différemment à
l'assemblée de façon un peu plus
violente c'est vrai mais bon c'est la
façon dont les choses se passent pour
avoir été au banc du gouvernement peut
vous dire que le Sénat est quand même
beaucoup plus respectueux et les choses
se passent différemment mais mais moi je
l'ai ressenti comme aussi une violence
c'est imposition de toujours avoir
raison ce mépris c'est de condescendance
voilà un moment un moment on en a on en
a assez Denis un dernier mot
justement est-ce que ce gouvernement il
peut continuer est-ce que Élisabeth Borg
la première ministre peut rester et
enclenché les réformes écoutez je ne
sais pas si c'est une histoire de
personne moi je crains que celle ou
celui qui lui succédera finalement sera
soumis toujours au tic-tac du président
qui continue à décider tout seuls qui
prend ses décisions dans son conseil de
défense maintenant la plupart du temps
entouré de quelques personnes je crois
qu'il demeure dans le la logique du
start-up nation c'est-à-dire qu'on est
avec deux ou trois personnes on décide
d'une chose et puis et puis on se lance
si ça passe c'est très bien si ça casse
et bien on passe à autre chose
immédiatement vous savez le président
était déjà dans dans la réforme d'après
souvenez-vous la
réforme n'était pas encore votée elle ne
l'a pas été que déjà nous étions dans la
présentation du SMU dans le texte
suivant nous sommes dans une moulinette
infernale ou dès lors qu'un texte est
présenté il doit être voté on passe à la
chose suivante voilà comme si on devait
comme si les projets de loi étaient
simplement sur une page d'un livre dont
on aurait à toute vitesse merci Denis
carro merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous depuis Nice on regarde la Une de
Nice-Matin Denis acte 10 c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci de nicaro et à
très vite évidemment on va parler d'un
autre sujet Hélène connu mourir puisque
pour aider les femmes qui ont des règles
douloureuses vous souhaitez instaurer un
congé menstruel on va voir en quoi ça
consiste avec notre journaliste Alex
Ponsard qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
en Seine-Saint-Denis on va écouter le
maire de Saint-Ouen
les femmes représentent 50% de la
population en France et la moitié
d'entre elles souffrent de règles
douloureuses ou de règles incapacitantes
à Saint-Ouen dans ma ville nous avons
2000 agents 60% de femmes 1200 femmes ce
qui signifie statistiquement que nous
avons entre 500 et 600 femmes
effectivement de règles douloureuses on
ne pouvait pas ne rien faire on a
analysé l'arsenal juridique l'arsenal
financier et on s'est dit on va mettre
en place ce congé menstruel et on est
vraiment fier qu'une bonne partie
désormais des villes suivre le pas on
sait que Paris a exprimé un vœu il y a
quelques semaines et de nombreuses
villes en boîte le parc alors avoir
maintenant si ce congé menstruel va être
généralisé au niveau national on peut
préciser qu'à l'automne dernier et bien
dans le débat au Sénat sur le budget
2023 la sénatrice écologiste Mélanie
Vogel avait déposé un amendement pour
créer ces congés menstruels mais le
Sénat avait rejeté cette proposition on
peut préciser aussi que cette mesure
fait quand même débat notamment dans les
milieux féministes car certaines
associations estiment que cela pourrait
créer une discrimination à l'embauche
pour les femmes donc il y a un débat
autour de cette mesure mais quand même
on peut dire quand 2021 2/3 des femmes
en France se disaient favorable à la
création du congé menstruel Hélène
konohamouret d'abord une petite
précision quand votre texte va être
déposé
alors quand il sera juridiquement solide
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui parce que en effet je suis
partie du terme congé qui veut qui
nécessitait en fait un amendement au
code du travail or aujourd'hui après
beaucoup de consultations notamment avec
le corps médical nous rend compte que
finalement ce congé menstruel devrait
être pris en charge par la Sécurité
Sociale et donc ne pas
ne nécessite pas une modification du
Code du travail mais du code de la
sécurité sociale tout simplement parce
que
[Musique]
la mise en place de celui-ci et
compliqué sur le plan budgétaire ou bien
évidemment on demande immédiatement
combien cela va coûter c'est absolument
impossible comme les arrêts maladie
finalement en France en faire une
estimation et c'est pour cela et dans la
façon dont vous les présenter j'essaye
de d'insuffler le plus de flexibilité
possible en effet de parler de
télétravail si la personne ne peut pas
se déplacer et de ne pas avoir
finalement ce congé menstruel comme un
épouvantail et cela a été le cas
malheureusement en Espagne vous avez en
effet mentionné que la loi était
promulguée mais elle n'a pas été encore
mise en place parce que les principaux
syndicats en fait espagnol aujourd'hui
bloque et continue à bloquer jusqu'au
moment de la promulgation des décrets
qui permettra la mise en place de cette
loi mais de trouver finalement le
support juridique correct donc moi je le
je m'inspire de ce qui se fait en
Espagne absolument et je vais d'ailleurs
rencontrer bientôt les députés qui eux
ne sont pas aussi avancés que moi
j'avais proposé trois articles justement
la possibilité d'introduction du
télétravail mais ce que j'ai fait
valider pour l'instant par les services
juridiques n'est pas suffisamment solide
donc j'attends mais je pense que en fait
il faut insérer
finalement ce congé menstruel dans le
cadre beaucoup plus large du bien-être
au travail et également de la santé des
femmes et donc c'est pour ça que ce
travail avec le corps médical est
important ou celui-ci aujourd'hui et
plutôt dans une logique de prendre en
compte pour la première fois finalement
c'est ces douleurs c'est la capacité de
travail et d'avoir peut-être finalement
un arrêt maladie qui serait ne serait
pas prescrit tous les mois mais qui
s'inscrirait dans une longue durée qui
ne nécessiterait pas à la femme chaque
mois d'aller voir ce que du coup si vous
n'arrivez pas à aboutir à une
proposition de loi vous pourriez déposer
par exemple un amendement dans la loi
travail qui serait examiné avant l'été
nous y réfléchissons et je vais voir
avec les députés où ils en sont parce
que leur consultation sont différentes
des miennes et en fait je pense qu'il
faut que nous le fasse nous travaillons
justement et puis surtout d'avoir un
soutien le plus large possible en effet
ma collègue a proposé cet amendement qui
a été rejeté je pense parce qu'il
n'avait peut-être pas été travaillé dans
le détail de ce que nous serons en
capacité de démontrer et de proposer la
prochaine fois avec la délégation ici au
droit des femmes et les chances voilà
nous avons besoin de se soutien
politique un peu plus large aussi et sur
le fond il y a actuellement très peu de
pays dans le monde qui ont créé ce congé
menstruel comment vous l'expliquez il y
a une forme de tabou sur ces douleurs je
le crois et je pense que justement le
fait d'en parler et c'est déjà une
victoire le texte viendra plus tard mais
je pense que nous avons besoin de
d'avancer de de
progresser avec des tabous et des choses
qui qui sont tout à fait naturelles et
le fait d'en parler fera aussi peut-être
mettre un coup d'arrêt à certaines
remarques désobligeantes de la part de
certains dont les femmes souffrent parce
que il y a la souffrance physique et il
a la souffrance psychologique également
donc je pense que le fait d'en parler
aujourd'hui et les médias ont très
largement finalement suivi ce sujet est
une très bonne chose en cas la nécessité
d'avoir une prise de conscience sur ces
douleurs menstruelles on a vu qu'il y a
une initiative locale avec la mairie de
Saint-Ouen ça peut renforcer cette prise
de conscience dans le territoire nous
avons une dizaine de PME aujourd'hui en
France qui l'ont instauré alors on voit
bien à chaque fois que c'est dans une
petite structure le Parti socialiste
également et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que finalement la mise en place
permet de tester aussi voilà sur le plan
budgétaire et peut-être d'apaiser les
craintes et les inquiétudes de certains
si je l'espère un jour cette proposition
de loi est acceptée une fois qu'elle est
juridiquement
bouclée fera en sorte et bien que voilà
il n'y aura pas de peur de la part des
syndicats des grandes entreprises et que
finalement il n'y aura pas de
d'opposition à cela merci Alex à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure on parlera de
la popularité d'Emmanuel Macron
on va parler de l'Afrique pour terminer
c'est un sujet évidemment que vous
suivez Hélène connu mourir le Burkina
Faso elle suspendu hier la diffusion de
la chaîne France 24 au motif qu'aurait
été diffusé sur la chaîne l'interview du
chef d'Al-Qaïda au maghrebislamique des
accusations sans fondement pour France
24 qui rappelle le livre jamais donné la
parole directement qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette décision des autorités
du Burkina Faso c'est une grande
tristesse en fait j'étais hier avec
Madame Sarragosse qui était vraiment
très très perspect absolument
à l'Assemblée des Français de l'étranger
qui se réunit toute la semaine à Paris
et elle était vraiment très très
perturbée par par cette nouvelle qu'elle
devait gérer
je pense que c'est un c'est un comment
assigne supplémentaire de la descente
aux enfers finalement
de pour le peuple burkinabè vous savez
c'est le plop des hommes valeureux qui
qui ne méritent absolument pas cela qui
aujourd'hui connaît des actes de
violence de plus en plus nombreux et qui
je l'espère ne fera pas appel à ceux qui
aujourd'hui sévissent au Mali je parle
de Wagner
je pense que les Burkinabè enfin je
l'espère résisteront à cette tentation
de se dire que s'il n'arrive pas à
résoudre les ce problème de violence
localement eux-mêmes feront appel à
l'extérieur mais vous parlez vous parlez
de Wagner là il y a eu la décision de
suspendre France 24 il y a quelques
semaines le Burkina Faso a demandé le
départ des soldats français bien sûr qui
étaient présents sur le territoire
est-ce que pour vous il y a une pression
de la Russie qui attise le sentiment
anti français sur place
bon alors bien sûr on connaît
aujourd'hui les actions de la Russie
mais de la Chine également et son palais
les seuls qui ont bien saisi le
opportunité par les réseaux sociaux
finalement de faire de la propagande
dans un premier temps et ensuite et bien
d'aller dans le sens de ce qu'il
souhaite c'est-à-dire finalement pousser
les Français dehors pour prendre leur
place mais pas la même place pas pour
les mêmes raisons non plus donc
c'est vrai qu'ils sont actifs mais il ne
faut pas simplement regarder
voilà ce que les Russes font pourquoi le
font-ils et pourquoi ont-ils aussi la
possibilité de le faire pourquoi ça
marche
pas parce que la France est en train de
perdre tout influence au sein donc il
faut que nous posions des questions
nous-mêmes d'abord sont simplement se
dire c'est la faute des Russes oui les
Russes sont là les Russes s'imposent de
plus en plus mais pourquoi qu'est-ce que
nous n'avons pas fait ou pas fait
correctement pour aujourd'hui être dans
situation où finalement notre
ambassadeur a été rappelé a été expulsé
en fait du Mali et aujourd'hui nous
avons une pression en effet ou la France
n'est plus bienvenue et pourquoi selon
vous est-ce qu'il y a eu est-ce qu'il y
a eu des erreurs de la part certaines
politiques publiques d'Emmanuel Macron
non pas forcément vous savez bon je l'ai
blâmer tout à l'heure pour un certain
nombre de choses
qui sont justifiés mais non je pense que
nous n'avons certainement pas pris
peut-être les bonnes décisions pendant
longtemps c'est-à-dire de mettre la la
finalement ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui enfin
l'accent sur l'aide publique au
développement sur le développement du
pays nous avons là une jeunesse
incroyablement
qualifié qui ne demande qu'à travailler
qui ne demande qu'à s'épanouir dans des
pays aujourd'hui qui sont dans une
grande pauvreté où la violence sévit
enfin voilà aussi pour des raisons
climatiques il y voilà une conjonction
de facteurs qui fait que ces pays n'y
arrivent pas et que notre présence qui
aurait été peut-être moins évident sur
moins évident sur le plan militaire mais
beaucoup plus sur le plan finalement du
développement économique du
développement éducatif et ainsi de suite
de ces pays ferait que nous serions pas
perçus de la même façon donc oui mais
bon en même temps nous avons répondu à
des appels à certains moments où ces
pays étaient je parle du Mali là je
reviens au Mali la France n'est pas
allée au Mali militairement toute seule
à la demande
un dernier mot il nous reste un peu de
temps sur les l'Assemblée des Français
de l'Étranger vous en avez parlé vous en
êtes membre en quoi ça consiste quels
sont les enjeux du moment alors ce sont
90 élus locaux c'est une réforme que
j'ai portée en 2013
où nous avons 443 Françaises et Français
qui sont élus localement dans tous les
pays du monde là où nous avons des une
présence diplomatique
éducative culturelle économique voilà et
donc ce sont un peu des conseils
municipaux nous avons créé des conseils
consulaires autour du consulat parce que
nous n'avons pas de mairie à l'étranger
et donc c'est le conseil consulaire
réunissent ces élus qui ont des
compétences dans tous les domaines que
je viens de d'exprimer et qui s'occupe
pour beaucoup font beaucoup de sociales
finalement s'occupent de ces communautés
françaises qui sont en expansion un peu
partout avec des jeunes qui pour
beaucoup particuliers et puis qui ont un
coup de coeur pour le pays et décide de
s'y installer
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous voir
pendant cette première